all right
so uh welcome everyone uh you've got
myself michael morrow ceo of genesis
trading
uh today we are going to talk about
corporate treasuries uh buying bitcoin
pros and cons who's doing it why they
may be doing it uh and most importantly
how they are doing it uh michael thank
you so much for uh for joining us today
thanks for having me happy to be here
absolutely let's maybe just get started
with a quick overview of genesis and
kind of your position in the market so
people understand your perspective
sure um so we are a cryptocurrency
focused uh crypto
prime broker um for for a lack of a an
easier um
terminology we help institutional
investors
hedge funds family offices um
corporations um
buy sell in the spot markets we do
derivatives we do borrow
lending we have a custody business um
all sort of in a
one stop um a service provider
effectively to institutional clients to
do whatever they want frankly kind of
within the cryptocurrency
space got it and so maybe we could just
start with
it seems like over the last 12 18 months
uh really a lot of the macro economic
factors uh
is what have driven uh both hedge funds
financial institutions and corporations
to start looking at bitcoin taking
bitcoin more seriously
from your perspective in the
conversations you've had what exactly
are cfos or corporate executives talking
about from a macro perspective and
what's
driving them to even consider bitcoin as
a potential asset to put on a balance
sheet
so um in my mind it's a confluence of a
couple of different things and certainly
kind of the macroeconomic
um environment and and kind of the the
central bank
reaction to the pandemic i think has
certainly been a driving factor
as to why um why now um
and and but alongside that um is
the maturation of the space right um if
this macroeconomic stuff happened in
2014
um and corporations would not be
thinking about doing this because kind
of
the pipes and the bridges and tunnels
and roads have not been built yet
um to be able to kind of like service
them adequately um
and so for one i think it really kind of
you know we started in 2013 and
and uh but there were no features there
was no borrow lending you know cussed
custodians was it really a thing um
and uh it would have been way too early
so i think kind of
how far the space has kind of come along
is number one number two
um because of kind of the you know the
the macroeconomic certainly like
tailwinds towards the asset class
um have really made okay is bitcoin an
asset class is crypto something we
should be paying attention to
and and for a long time obviously you
got like stocks
you got bonds you got fx you got some
commodities
um as sort of like options for for
people to kind of consider and i think
kind of bitcoin popped up on the radar
um for a lot of these institutions and
and at the very least
it was let's study it let's take a look
let's see how it works um and that's
what really kind of got them down
the rabbit hole got it and so when you
think about
if you're sitting in that seat let's say
you're the treasurer the cfo or
another executive at a corporation it
feels like
uh there's probably two main goals and
you correct me if i'm wrong one
is they want to protect the value that
they
have on that balance sheet and then two
is there's potential
options to grow the value as well is
that kind of a fair characterization of
what the two
kind of main drivers of what they're
looking for i think that's right look
most of the time treasury departments of
corporations are not there to like make
money
right they hopefully have a main line of
business that is actually doing that for
you so the treasury functions mostly for
for preservation protection capital
protection frankly
to not lose um the the value um
and and certainly i think there's an
aspect of
can we um can we protect the value of
what we have that's one
and to your point yes it'd be great if
we there is
a a possibility for us to increase value
and have that but number three and i'll
put this in a separate category is
the digitization the tokenization
of assets is real and we should get
comfortable with digital wallets right
this idea of
working with traditional custodians and
brokers is kind of one thing but this
trend is here to stay
we can experiment by playing around with
bitcoin today because directionally
that's where this whole world is going
so there's an educational aspect of all
of this too that i think is kind of
driving a lot of the corporate
treasurers and cfos to be looking at
this
for sure and then as you've seen uh them
go after that store of value
uh it feels like bitcoin kind of fits
nicely in that narrative
maybe like a digital gold uh 2.0
whatever the kind of the the
nomenclature you want to use is
but also it seems like more and more
people are interested in the yield that
can be generated
um what are you seeing when it comes to
maybe the growing of the acid-base it's
not the main focus but it seems like
people
uh don't mind the fact that there could
be yield to generate here and so what
have you learned in conversations on
that front
most of the time treasurers don't have
like
new things to invest in right typically
they buy
very very boring plain vanilla you know
like government bonds
as a safe play to get in and
and and and kind of going back to the
macroeconomic kind of point about
kind of the real inflate inflation rates
and being like on a real risk adjusted
you know inflation-adjusted perspective
i'm down by buying this basket of like
municipal bonds right and so
i said okay if that is kind of the
traditional capital preservation method
let's kind of look elsewhere and let's
look at bitcoin and certainly
it's volatile we'll obviously kind of
get into the the risks associated with
with corporations particularly kind of
doing this
at the same time um we have
developed borrowing and lending markets
and so you can say okay i want to borrow
buy bitcoin um and lend it out
and earn yield on my bitcoin that's one
and number two
is i don't have to liquidate that
bitcoin to get liquidity
um so i could post my bitcoin as
collateral and get u.s dollar
borrowings against it should i have some
needs kind of
on the fiat side as far as it relate to
working capital and i think
you know for a long time i think it's
like if i buy bitcoin i have to sell it
if i have to get access to dollars and i
think sort of the
the evolution of the lending market i
think kind of frankly made bitcoin
a more useful asset and and and you know
they'll
happily borrow at really really low loan
to values i think they're just kind of
happy to have the ability to kind of
post bitcoin as collateral and get
dollars on it
um and and and i think it makes bitcoin
even more useful as an asset if you
don't actually have to sell it and incur
like the tax gains and losses and all
that stuff
absolutely so today if a treasurer cfo
corporate executive comes to you and
says hey you know we're trying to think
about
bitcoin as part of a diversified
portfolio of assets
what's your response or how do you kind
of uh explain to somebody why they
should have that bitcoin exposure
so um i i think it's really important
first of all that like companies kind of
go
into this and and come reach their
conclusion
that maybe bitcoin isn't for them and
maybe that's an unexpected thing for me
to be telling you about since i have a
business kind of
centered around transactions in crypto
um but what's most
important i really believe is kind of
going down the rabbit hole yourself and
coming up with
kind of conclusions on their own so i
think the first outcome is
why are you doing this like what is the
ultimate purpose for you to kind of
going down this exercise as far as to
why you want to do it
and most of the time people focus on the
trade right they're like
how do i do this how do i talk to the
trader and how does the settlement occur
in all of it
but in most instances and i tell
everybody this the trade is the easy
part
that is the last step in what is often
three to six months of diligence um
about how it works and my first question
is
you know does legal know about this
or have you talked to accounting about
this and most of the time it's
oh we're gonna get to it right and and
frankly like
i i always kind of come back to okay
that's great but let's get all the
stakeholders
involved here early on and and for us
you can talk to my legal you can talk to
my my finance team
and hold your hand as to how you should
be thinking about this whole thing don't
worry about the trade the trade's
done in five seconds it'll settle in an
hour
and get this all done but it's really
like a six month long process of
diligence around the ass class to make
sure they know what they're getting
themselves into
who's doing this is this just like the
crypto and bitcoin ludites uh who have
infiltrated a corporation
is it crypto companies is this uh
kind of traditional technology companies
like who are you seeing actually
uh be interested in it and then who's
executing on it
so obviously throughout 2020 there was a
ton of focus on the the microstrategies
and the teslas and the squares
um publicly traded you know us based
companies with a tech bent
um to to what they do um and
our tech are sort of payments fintech
perspective
and and you know for our first clients
as it relates to this product
was of that vertical um so
us some of them are publicly traded some
of them were not
and thinking about how do i execute this
how do we think about this now
over time as i think um i think the
press
journalists kind of picked up on bitcoin
as treasury
it expanded so one of the first things
we noticed was latin america
was non-us clients both
public and private in latin america is
trying to say
how do i do this um i'm interested
um i am a fintech there is a crypto
payments play to my business
and i feel like i think i need to have a
crypto play i need to think this is the
future
i need to incorporate it and certainly
i'm starting to accept it as
a medium of payments but the best way
for me to learn how to do this is if i
buy some of my own
right and and and that is true
regardless whether you're an individual
or your company the best way for you to
learn how all of this works
is like buy some and play with it
yourself and so there was that
and then we started transacting kind of
latin american clients and frankly a lot
of them
store value inflation hedge plays really
really well
if your native country has like 40 50
inflation
um of kind of your fiat currency and so
i think the bitcoin narrative i think
really kind of took hold
and then there was southeast asia um
and we started to see tremendous demand
from companies and corporations in
southeast asia
that again had either you know maybe
some capital control restrictions or
there were questions about hey how do i
move funds around the world easily
started to kind of take an interest
right and so many of them are
tech there's no question about it there
isn't like a textile
manufacturing company putting bitcoin on
their balance sheet but
it has to kind of ultimately fit into
what they're building
but those are the the companies that are
the most active
absolutely and when you think about the
types of companies we talked about
geography
uh how much of this is just crypto
companies in those geographies versus
uh traditional tech companies uh versus
maybe what we would consider like
highly conservative large blue chip you
know publicly traded companies
i think there's a lot of rumors about
some of that but but not necessarily so
much
action yet so just when you look at kind
of the spectrum of industry
and also maybe sophistication or
conservatism any
insights there that you've gleaned from
the conversations or the
partners you guys have worked with let's
separate out companies that have
actually done something
versus the companies that are like in
the diligence studying
how does this work mode right the
biggest
um industrials the corporations are very
much in the
let's i want to learn how this works um
and and maybe down the line we'll invest
right we'll
we'll do something um and and and
it's certainly the smaller more nimble
companies um that have certainly been
the guys to
ultimately execute right um and and so
you know blue chip companies have
frankly like a lot more to lose
um by making sort of a a bitcoin play
especially if you don't have a crypto
angle or a fintech bench to your company
um i certainly have i think uh you know
a lot more explaining to do to their
shareholders
um as to why they're doing this in
bitcoin and and so reputationally and
from uh they have way more to protect i
think so
um they're they're on the studying side
the execution side
are going to be the the smaller we've
seen a lot more private companies than
than public
um as far as who's who's ultimately kind
of doing it and
and and that's kind of the typical
profile and then what about public verse
private in terms of uh the the types of
companies
obviously private companies seems to be
much more pervasive there than in the
public markets
uh but definitely we saw you know as
part of 2020 into 2021 a couple of
public companies start to do this
any insights on public versus private so
um you know the privates um certainly
well for one there's way more private
companies around the world than public
and so
naturally you know just kind of based on
that i think you end up with
more private clients and frankly as a
public company
a lot of the issues matter tax
accounting
legal all that matters but the key
difference is the public disclosure
right and and what is material what do i
need to disclose
to shareholders do i file an 8k
what's the materiality test all of that
stuff i think
plays into it and you know do i disclose
this as a risk factor
in my 10k do i need to establish
you know employee trading policies um of
bitcoin
uh within my own organization so i think
there is
way more like hoops to ultimately kind
of jump through as
a public company and and and you know
and and i think there's a
large percentage of folks who are who
have done the homework to say hey
it's a lot we have to do here as a
public company
it's not worth it for me to just
allocate one percent of my treasury
like if i'm gonna do this i need to make
it like worth my while
and so you know there's a go big or go
home element to it i think that said hey
if we're gonna do this let's really do
this and
and and for you know for for one reason
or another i think they're saying
let's let's wait until this feels like
the water is a bit warmer
do you have an idea of what that
threshold is that kind of makes it
worth it you said one percent probably
is too small is it like a
five percent or is it like 25
and any kind of thoughts there so the
smaller companies frankly
start with one percent but they have no
by no means
even private companies are gonna do this
for one percent right so they do
this started with one percent with a
goal to let's get to 10
15 over time um when once like we figure
out how this all works and we'll kind of
get comfortable with the asset class and
certainly working with genesis let's
like
you know increase our allocation
certainly over time um
the other guys are like look the one big
thing is custody
right it's how do i safely keep my
crypto
um and some companies are like do i
build my own storage
wallets cold storage all of it or do i
work with a
you know an independent like third-party
regulated custodian told me we're going
to get that done
even that decision of trying to think
through
which custodian do i work with is a
hassle
because you got to do tech diligence
insurance
you know liability all of that stuff and
so they said wait
i'm just going to wait till there's a
bitcoin etf okay
i'm just going to wait until there's an
exchange to your product in the united
states
that i can just kind of buy call my
broker and say go out and buy me but
you know so the bitcoin etf and that'll
be that but
you know because they don't know when
that's ultimately going to be whether
that's 12 months or 18 months or
or further out they still want to do the
homework around the asset class to
figure out what it is so that they can
ultimately kind of get into it and then
you don't have to worry about the
custody thing because the fund is
ultimately responsible
got it uh before we move on to kind of
execution uh what about
gold or do you see companies dropping
gold
uh to do this do companies that you talk
to have gold on their balance sheet
uh do they kind of skip over that as a
store of value option
just how does that come up in
conversation at all
it's funny you know obviously we our
affiliates
grayscale guys i've been running this
drop gold campaign
a lot of these corporates never had it
they had nothing to drop right
um and so uh that's been really really
interesting for
for us is that they haven't really
thought about this as a replacement for
something else it literally is
i need to cut back on my fixed income
allocation
um because you know in terms of real
yield it's negative
um and why would i invest in something
that is guaranteed to lose money over
time
as opposed to something that over
certainly long enough time horizon to
actually protect it
got it um for those that are watching
live right now
uh if you have questions for michael uh
or about this topic make sure that
you're just putting
them into the chat and then uh after
another 10 or 15 minutes i'll start just
reading out the questions and we'll do
our best to get them all answered
uh but just use that chat functionality
to send us your questions
michael i want to talk about how to
actually do it the actual execution of
this so
i'm a cfo a treasurer corporate
executive i've done my homework
uh you've you know i've talked with you
you've basically scared the hell out of
me in terms of the risk disclosures and
all the things that i have to do and i'd
say you know what
i'm still uh convicted i want to do this
uh whether it's one percent or ten
percent
uh i call you up and i say all right
let's do it
what happens like what are the actual
steps in terms of
uh executing the uh investment storing
the investment
and kind of just walk me through like
the the trade itself for a corporate to
actually buy bitcoin and put on a
balance sheet
so the first one of the first things
obviously is working out
all of the vendors and service providers
you ultimately work with now
this is after the three to six months of
internal diligence and working with tax
people and
this is how you account for bitcoin on
your balance sheet this is
the tax implications this is the aml kyc
um and the providence of bitcoins to
know that three holders ago
um it wasn't used to buy guns and drugs
on the internet like
all of that stuff still matters you know
especially to like public corporations
that have shareholders and
you know there's kind of reputational
risk associated with kind of getting
involved in the asset class now
let's see you've done all that the next
question is who's authorized to trade
who can we take instructions from mr
corporation who's authorized to
ultimately face genesis and be the trade
right most of the time they'll be like
look here's the list here's the
authorizing notorious now we know
we do the the confirmations and all that
kind of stuff ultimately comes time to
do a trade
what they do typically is is a t-wap
approach
i want to buy 10 million dollars worth
of bitcoin
um so i want that executed over three
hours six hours 12 hours
um so that there's minimal impact in the
marketplace
these guys do not have any interest in
moving the market
um and so whatever time horizon for the
10 million dollar trade i want to do
is kind of the the t-wap that i kind of
want to run it for
and so they buy a little bit every
single hour across
you know all the various liquidity
avenues available to genesis
and then we just kind of pass along kind
of the execution all the prices and
fills that they got filled out of
various places
and that's ultimately how the actual
trade is ultimately done
now settlement typically involves a
third-party custodian
all right we wait for the funds to come
in and ultimately they just give us an
address to say hey i need the bitcoins
kind of sent to this address we'll do a
bunch of test transactions and
all of that to confirm um and then we
send the the bitcoins out to the address
and the custodian then from there
obviously kind of the custodian manages
it whether that's internally within
genesis
or they may work with another custodian
um independently
to kind of get that done but like and
like i said all of this is done
the actual trade execution might be done
in an hour three hours six hours
um or from time to time be like i just
wanna fill just fill me
said okay so on market you know within
five seconds you'll do a million dollar
trade or five million dollar
trade and then we settle the transaction
ultimately gets done but the larger
transactions kind of the 50 million
100 million kind of larger guys are way
more we
do it over 24 hours 48 hours let's not
move the market
and just kind of get me done are you
able to say what the largest transaction
you've done
for any corporation no names but just to
give people a sense of the size
it's nine figures okay so nine figures
when somebody wants to do that uh as
you've kind of
uh already alluded to one is they don't
want to move the price of the asset if
possible right but buying nine figures
can
can potentially do that and so what it
sounds like they're really doing is they
come to you and say hey
you know we want to buy the nine figures
worth of uh of bitcoin we're gonna put
it on the balance sheet
uh and over the next i don't know six
hours 12 hours or whatever
can you go do that without moving the
market what you guys are really doing is
you're almost serving as an intermediary
or a desk for them
that goes and hits all these different
liquidity providers and you're buying up
bitcoin on various different avenues or
uh
liquidity points and then you're
bringing it all back and you eventually
fill an entire nine-figure order
but because you're doing it in so many
different venues that's really what
you're doing
uh and over a period of time that's how
you're preventing the actual market
price moving
correct it's the number of venues and
time right if i had to do nine figures
in an hour
a hundred percent i don't have a choice
but to move the market
um but that's kind of when the the time
horizon over which the
the t-wop the time-weighted average
price execution ultimately happens that
like minimizes the impact of the
marketplace
got it and how much does this cost me
right so let's just use easy numbers
uh i give you a hundred dollars i say
hey i want to go ahead and buy bitcoin
put on the balance sheet
how much bitcoin am i actually gonna get
am i getting you know
99 uh dollars and 95 cents or
just walk me through kind of the fees
that are usually are associated with
something like this on a regular
t-wap transaction technically genesis
isn't taking any risk
we're just serving as kind of the middle
man liquidity provider
um and then passing along the execution
cost plus kind of the genesis fee right
so then the genesis fee can be
a basis point two basis points we're not
talking like large large numbers
in terms of actual basis points but you
know back in the day
when we first got started we could
charge like a point we could charge a
one percent to a point and a half two
percent maybe
on a million dollar trade that has
shrunk to that point
where you know you're you're you're
you're you know making a basis point or
two
why is it shrunk so much is it just pure
kind of not necessarily commoditization
but just competition in the market
uh and everyone has kind of their own uh
advantage or competitive nature
or is there something else that's
driving those prices down ultimately
um number one is liquidity um and and it
is
a much bigger asset class the market cap
is higher the the 24-hour volume is much
higher so
it is way less e-liquid um than it used
to be it truly used to be an e-liquid
asset um
now it's about as out as liquid and
asset as you can possibly find
um and i think that makes it certainly
easier to source
you know kind of buys and sells um
number two certainly i think competition
um i think there's lots of people that
are trying to kind of do what we do and
and we're client service oriented
business um
so uh making our clients ultimately
happy and wanting to do
a second trade or third trade with us is
certainly a factor and number three um
you know it's kind of
the spot trading is just one thing we do
um we have clients who said hey um i
want to buy bitcoin
and then sell calls against it if i
think that for a while
prices are going to be staying around
where we are and i can clip some yield
um by selling some options against a
portion of my position
that is a way for me to to kind of get
that now i may want to lend some out to
genesis
um or borrow against all of that stuff
so i think there's lots of other ways in
terms of economics
that genesis is able to make the money
that is not necessarily in that you know
like that with that one trade
and then what about privacy right so if
i'm a big corporation
in the public or private markets and i
want to do this i'm probably worried
about people finding out about it before
i announce it or before i actually do it
what's the privacy look like from me to
genesis and then
through to the actual liquidity venues
that genesis is sourcing this from
and is there a way for people to you
know know that i'm doing it or is it a
fairly private process
uh i wish i can talk about the clients
we've worked with um but i i
can't and i don't for lots of different
reasons and and the fact that
you know we've done 9 billion 10 billion
of transactions with corporations
um and you know and we have not there's
no rumor in the marketplace that
somebody kind of did something with
genesis i think kind of speaks to
confidentiality and how about how how
serious we ultimately kind of take it
and
and two you know we talk about you know
removing intermediaries
from kind of this decentralized
marketplace and ecosystem around crypto
there's a lot of benefit to having an
intermediary in this instance
of somebody going out to the marketplace
and doing the execution for you
and ultimately not knowing who our end
account
and client is and so our clients do not
know
um who we're doing it and frankly that
that's also because we work with so many
different other clients
that it's hard to like isolate into that
one trade was for this one client
yeah it's uh it's pretty incredible 10
billion dollars of corporate
uh bitcoin buys and no leaks is uh is a
great testament to you guys
talk to me about security um and storage
so
obviously uh if you're sending the
bitcoin to an
address for kind of a third party uh
custodian that's one thing if you guys
are helping to
provide that uh that's another thing um
what does that security look like uh
through both the sourcing
uh the settlement process and storage
and then also insurance or any sort of
safeguards or safety nets that are
provided in the process
ultimately as it relates to um the the
custody piece we all talk about
tech we all talk about hey we have best
in class technology and
and we use that technology this
technology wants one better than the
other
most of these corporations and companies
aren't
um they're not savvy enough to be able
to tell
what's better um one versus the other
you really have to kind of know the
technology and be a technologist
or cryptographer or security expert to
like be able to differentiate
one from the other right and and so i
don't think the marketplace
um corporations included frankly gives
the full
credit on tech which also comes down to
two things one's brand
um are you standing behind your product
who are you are you known in the
marketplace do you have something to
lose
um if something should happen and number
two is insurance
um and you know who is your insurance
underwriter
how much premium coverage do you do how
do you segregate assets
all of that stuff and frankly that is
probably the
longest part of the diligence process
um because yes they want to know the
text because they need the documentation
to like file it internally and make sure
they can get proper
sign off it's i want to talk to your
insurance underwriter can can you put me
in touch
um can i see your insurance premiums
what do you cover for what are you not
covered for and how do we ultimately
kind of think about it so
that is by far way more important than
the actual execution
because that's an ongoing relationship
um and
as opposed to like a moment in time
transaction
so that is definitely definitely on the
minds of of our clients
what's up guys bang bang i hope you're
enjoying this conversation but before we
go any further i want to quickly tell
you about today's sponsor
blockfy blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use their cryptocurrency
exchange and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
again blockfi.com pomp go check it out
and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it
for sure and i guess part of this too is
uh and i'm cheating here because i
already know this
but uh regulation um and kind of the
financial oversight from regulators from
uh government agencies uh there's a
reason why
genesis has built a brand there's a
reason why you're able to get the
insurance but maybe just talk a little
bit about
what that regulation environment looks
like and whether that's an advantage or
whether that's just a
kind of table stakes expectation at this
point from corporations shown up by
bitcoin
so our whole you know kind of ethos
around genesis has been um institutions
are coming um
they're going to want to work with
regulated entities
um as kind of their trusted counterparty
and so we should strive for the kind of
the highest level of regulation you can
possibly find
which is why genesis trading has been
the scc finner registered broker dealer
with the bit license the new york city
department of furniture services
regulation often kind of gets a bad rap
i think kind of in in the crypto world
for lots of different reasons some of
them i think are valid frankly
at the same time though that's what
people care about that's
that's a check the box item for a lot of
our
our counterparties to say hey we can get
involved in this asset class because
there is a regulated entity that we can
ultimately kind of face right
and the same thing on the custody side i
think they're like okay how are you
regulated as a custodian do you have the
appropriate licenses do you have
sock two certification how are the
cryptography certification that you
ultimately have and so
all of these things i think kind of
speaks to a lot to
you know picking vendors and who do you
work with and why
um especially because they're kind of
good questions
they're like where did you source the
bitcoin how do you you know
and and being able to say hey we brought
it through a broker dealer
that is and sec and finra have oversight
into how they work with i think is an
easy answer for a lot of clients to be
able to give
all right last question and then we'll
start taking questions from the audience
is uh
esg bitcoin ofac compliant bitcoin
blocks
there's all kinds of uh things what
we'll call them
uh that are floating around bitcoin as
corporations and financial institutions
start to look at the space
uh what insights do you have there is
that a
popular talk track uh do you get
questions on it or is that something
that maybe the the mainstream press has
run with but but hasn't quite caught on
yet in the conversations with
corporations
it's somewhere in the middle i'd say so
it's funny our core clients
are like i want the cheap bitcoin right
like
the cheapest bitcoin out there um
and and uh because they obviously have a
different mandate as far as returning
capital to their investors right and so
but corporations
have brands they have esg efforts they
have
um uh shareholders in some cases and so
yes they cannot be looking to
invest in something that is destructive
to the environment now
on the one hand we do a lot of work to
kind of demystify
dispel myths around you know bitcoin
boiling the oceans and
and all of that number two though i
think at the very least they want to be
neutral right that that somehow the
their
their bitcoin um you know
getting involved in certain the asset
class has been at best at worst neutral
to the environment and so
lots of conversations around can i buy
bitcoin
that is obviously 100 renewable energy
money
you can't really do that today um but i
think that'll
certainly narrative change over time and
then there's carbon you know tax credits
can i buy the bitcoin and then can i buy
some offsets
and then yes that makes my all in cost
of bitcoin more expensive
right at the same time though i can tell
my board or i can tell my shareholders
that like you know we're doing our part
to at least be neutral
in in kind of so it matters um certainly
to um to
to to bigger companies frankly that
comes up way more often in conversations
yeah absolutely fascinating to hear kind
of the difference um
we're gonna start taking questions here
there's a whole bunch of them so maybe
we can kind of try to go through these
as quick as we can the last 20 minutes
or so
uh the first is all about how many
discovery calls or kind of initial
contacts with companies
actually lead to the trigger being
pulled so you know top of funnel
hey we had a discussion with a company
what percentage of those folks actually
end up buying bitcoin putting on the
balance sheet
so there are lots of companies who
frankly
um impressed me in that they've done a
lot of the legwork before they reach out
so they know who their service providers
are they know who they want to work with
and give us a call those guys
are like you know give me 24 hours 48
hours of diligence and let's just go
right then there are a bunch of
companies that
have gone down the rabbit hole and said
all right this is on our 2022
investment committee topic so nothing
this year
and and and will refocus next year
very few i would say you know we
probably have fielded i don't even know
hundreds of conversations with different
companies
i'm going to say less than 10 have said
no way no will we ever like invest
invested
like definitively say no to bitcoin
investment it's it's always maybe not
this year
um but certainly kind of within the next
you know 12 to
24 months and so it's hard to say how
many people have executed
um ultimately because there's so many
guys we're on this next year or whatnot
but as far as
counterparties that have transacted um
with us so far
we're you know it's probably somewhere
around 30 to 40 different clients
have done transactions um and but some
of them have
have bought sold re-bought
um and so it's all kind of transactions
as they kind of figure out the liquidity
of this asset class i think they're
doing their homework
about how deep the market is and all of
that kind of in their transactions as
well
wayne asks what percentage of companies
that hold bitcoin on their balance sheet
are borrowing money to buy that bitcoin
and maybe an extension of that is what
percentage of companies do you think are
borrowing against the bitcoin on their
balance sheet
so um number so uh i'll i'll separate on
two different ways
most companies are saying hey i'm do one
to two percent
um and so they don't really need to
borrow bid borrow dollars to go out and
do it
right and frankly i think that's kind of
the more um
prevalent client base as opposed to the
michael saylor i'm
issuing debt into the marketplace and
doing a levered long play into bitcoin
like that's not
by any means the typical strategy
um as it relates to do it now we have
seen companies that said i want to buy
bitcoin
they did it and then they had some you
know whatever working capital need and
so they need to borrow against that
bitcoin
um that's been only been a handful
frankly most of these companies though
are not doing large enough transactions
so that like it ties up their working
capital that they wanted to ultimately
do elsewhere
um so it is it's relatively small
got it teresa asks uh about the gap
rules and whether they disfavor crypto
investment and what you think about uh
the rules
potentially changing in the future so
um it's a good question um and certainly
within kind of gap and
and you know principles bitcoin
gets treated as and is intangible so
it's effectively like goodwill
on a company's balance sheet and you
have to run impairment tests
over time so um and it's either
you know the purchase price you bought
it at or
the lowest price bitcoin traded during
the quarter
it is not the low price at the end of
the it's not the price at the end of the
quarter and whichever one's lower it is
literally the lowest price it traded on
during the quarter in which you're
reporting so what it does
is it creates this difference between
the fair
value and kind of the carrying value of
the balance sheet because of this timing
difference
and frankly the way gaap forces you to
account for it right and so
bitcoin could have been bought at a
dollar it could be trading at ten
dollars you will not see that anywhere
within the company's balance sheet um so
what companies have to do then is resort
to non-gaap measures
and frankly i think a lot of non-gaap
disclosures and things like that get
again get a bad rap for showing
something that is inconsistent with
accounting guidelines but this forces
you
to actually tell what's ultimately
happening now ask bitcoin becomes more
of an investable asset
i'm hopeful that you are able to
actually get mark to market
treatment of bitcoin and sort of move it
above the line
um higher up kind of on the on the asset
side as opposed to continue to be
treated as an intangible asset because
that's not at all reflecting you know
kind of market value of what it is that
the company owns
it feels like a common sense thing that
uh that we probably should update those
so uh we will see when that happens uh
someone asks
kate duffy jr uh is genesis seeing any
interest
in bitcoin from university foundations
not necessarily just corporations
uh but other foundations we know that
mit harvard and yale have bitcoin
positions through those foundations
uh anything there that you're seeing
we've seen um
interest from as low as high schools
um that have a bitcoin allocation um for
their kind of like high school endowment
situations like private schools
obviously
um within within the us and so yes
absolutely we've seen
you know we've seen interest from all
kinds of different groups and
frankly people that i never would have
characterized as
likely being bitcoin holders um you know
high schools private high schools
would not have made my top 10 list but
you know
but they're buyers amazing ryan jeffs
asks at what point do these large otc
corporate trades reflect in the price of
bitcoin does it impact
price positively and maybe just more so
how you think about the relationship
between
price and corporations actually putting
bitcoin on their balance sheet
ultimately um you know these guys are
long-term holders and so anytime you are
able to add
long-term investors into the equation i
think is a good thing
i think it reduces the amount of float
or like circulating you know supply of
bitcoin available for purchase at any
given time and
and certainly if you're a long bitcoin i
i think you should welcome
way more of long-term longer time
horizon
investors into the marketplace and um
you know
and and and so i would 100 believe that
when we're out in the marketplace we're
actually going out and buying bitcoin
right so
um any any of that stuff i think is is
certainly a
positive into the ecosystem especially
if they're doing small bits they're not
going to turn around and sell
right away most of them and i think
that's that's certainly a uh
a positive thing ultimately for bitcoin
if you're able to increase the number of
investors
doug asks with the well-known volatility
aspect and risk factors associated how
do companies factor that into adding
bitcoin and does a frenzy
or a sell-off like we're currently
seeing trigger knee-jerk reactions
and i think he's specifically asking
just you know do people go dump or make
kind of emotional decisions once they
put on the balance sheet
i think that's um you know and i'll put
corporates
in the institutional investor bucket
um and what do we find across
institutional investors in general
is that they have a strategy they have a
plan and they
generally stick to their plan as to why
they're doing
you know what they're doing and when
they're ultimately doing it and so
days like today um are gonna be days in
which
okay is this like when we double down
is this when we go from one percent to
two percent allocation
as opposed to panic selling um most of
the time kind of the more
it's the the panic selling is a more
retail driven phenomenon
we don't really see a lot of it kind of
on the institutional side of the house
and so
um you know they may be wrong in their
plan
um but generally speaking they approach
a new association's investment with a
plan and they ultimately kind of like
stick to it
rather than like you know panic selling
into the marketplace
h asks recently u.s sec commissioners
said the sec
needs to approve bitcoin etf do you
think in 2021 a bitcoin etf will be
approved
uh and then maybe i'll add uh how would
that change
corporation's relationship with bitcoin
putting it on their balance sheet and
making an investment decision
here's my view um on a bitcoin etf in
the u.s
um chairman gensler a few weeks ago
um talked about regulating crypto
exchanges
that the sec um or frankly that federal
regulator needs to step in and be
more um you know coming out with like
regulations for how to
properly govern uh crypto exchange i
actually believe
that that's the precursor to the etf
like once the sec is able to say hey we
are regulating these exchanges now we
believe in fair and orderly markets that
investors are protected
then i think the etf can be created
because you have better market
surveillance and restrictions
all of that stuff that i think the scc
has historically said
they're not approving bitcoin because we
we have no idea what's happening on the
exchanges so
but like i'm
i i don't believe it's a 2021
event i it's gonna take time to come up
with the rules of the road for exchanges
implement them and then follow them um
so
which is why i'm in uh maybe late 2022
early 23
camp as opposed to uh for a big point
etf because i still think you got to
come up with this regulation for
exchanges first
now as it relates to corporates um it
makes it so much easier to buy bitcoin
right um and so i actually do think that
having a easily investable product
like a bitcoin etf and you can just call
up your broker and buy bitcoin
and not have to worry about all the a
lot of the stuff that i talked about
today
um you know just by putting it into an
etf
it becomes a security right it becomes a
security on your balance sheet and then
you can mark the market that security as
like you would any other security a lot
of the
accounting issues about holding the
underlying bitcoin ultimately kind of go
away within the security form so
i think i think that would be a a huge
benefit i think for corporations to
invest
hector asks does a focus on insurance
mean that the technology is subject to
breaches
basically uh if the corporations are so
focused on that maybe why are they
so what's funny is and and i'm knocking
on wood as i say this
um you know as far as breaches and
security incidents i'm
unaware of a custodian getting breached
um exchanges get hacked um
and and and hot wallets and and whatnot
but i'm unaware of a
custodian like their sole business is
custodying bitcoin
been breached maybe i just don't know
what they are um
and and and whatnot but like for the
most part we have not really kind of
seen it and so i feel like on the
security side custodians
that their single line of focus is the
custody business
um they still focus on it because i
think custodians compete amongst
themselves
to have the best in tech and they're
certainly kind of reinvesting into the
technology so but like that focus on
insurance
i don't think necessarily means that
their tech isn't as good
got it doug asks with the rise of
corollary etfs
how long if ever do you think it will
take for traditional bds fidelity schwab
etc
to offer crypto directly on their
platforms and maybe would that shift the
way that corporations
uh would potentially get their exposure
so i think a part of the um
the the task i think is you know a lot
of these companies
um are all for like they have a separate
entity that does the crypto stuff
and i think some of it's like ring
fencing crypto risk as opposed to the
actual broker dealer like the fidelity
offering of their their ultimate product
i do think though
that the sec has had um
certainly concerns about a broker dealer
custodying non-securities i don't think
they want
broker dealers to start custodying other
assets that aren't typically securities
through their broker dealer balance
sheet um and so until
that treatment and kind of that thought
process changes
i think you won't see traditional broker
dealers offering outright crypto i think
they will continue to offer security
forms
of crypto and also the capital risk
waiting
um of bitcoin for broker dealers is
incredibly punitive
um it is 100 write down um of your
equity for every dollar of bitcoin you
hold
um so it is incredibly equity expensive
um to to have bitcoin on your balance
sheet for a broker dealer
and i run one so i i know the pain um
so until the the sec changes their
capital treatment of bitcoin
i think it'll make it really really hard
for more mobile broker dealers to get
involved
awesome uh last question we have if
anyone else has other questions please
put them in
or or forever hold your piece uh
manjo asks how companies are handling
the esg related questions
on the conviction of the bitcoin
holdings on their balance sheet so
basically if they already have bitcoin
on their balance sheet
or going through that process how are
publicly traded companies handling those
esg
questions uh are they doing specific
things uh maybe carbon credits etc to uh
to kind of mitigate some of those
concerns
so some of these companies that already
are along bitcoin are trying to come up
with you know
other um you know donations to
environmental you know agencies and and
non-profits and things like that with an
environmental mission to help offset
whatever they think that they've already
ultimately done but frankly
there are some companies that just don't
care about the stuff either um so i
certainly don't want to paint uh you
know with a broad brush that all these
companies care about the environment
um more companies probably should
frankly but
a lot of them simply do not and kind of
see bitcoin as yet another investment
and
and and they kind of treat that treat
that accordingly and i think the other
thing is
um beyond bitcoin right how do we think
about ethereum how do they think about
other coins for for corporate treasury
and and certainly we've seen companies
um take an ethereum allocation right to
their balance sheet
um but they haven't really gone to like
the next coin
whatever that might be and some of that
is regulation
um i think there's certainly fear that
whatever they buy
the sec might did simon that's also
security
and then there's lots of questions about
you accounted it for improperly
you didn't buy it for a broker dealer or
it wasn't custodied by
the securities custodian so having that
regulatory gray area
around yeah bitcoin is not a security
ethereum's not a security
but the sec hasn't really opined on
anything else i think kind of prevents
corporations from from you know
expanding beyond
just kind of like bitcoin and ethereum
into other asset classes
yeah it's uh it's really interesting
when you start thinking about bitcoin
and then what else what percentage of
uh folks that you guys have worked with
or talked with uh that put bitcoin on
the balance sheet put uh ethereum or
some other asset on the balance sheet as
well is it a high small
five five five percent five to ten
something like that
okay and so if that five percent is
uh of those who have bitcoin on their
balance sheet then we're talking sub one
percent of
all corporations you speak to end up
putting ethereum on just killing
the law of large numbers yeah and
growing i'm assuming right
okay uh two more questions and then we
will wrap up wayne asks how can genesis
help us bitcoin miners expand their
operations
as the china crackdown plays out so
the beauty of um how we're structured we
have an affiliate
entity wing called foundry digital that
focuses
on uh mining and staking
and and uh you know and and genesis
helps
um on the equipment financing side and
kind of providing capital
through the foundry business um into the
to the mining and staking community
so um you know the the china crackdown
of last few days i think has been
you know has certainly i think great in
terms of decentralizing hash power
around the world and
and frankly kind of helping you know the
us um continue to kind of gain market
share and so
we work with our uh mining and staking
um affiliate to kind of accomplish
up through mostly like lending um and
and and what not equipment financing and
whatnot to to those entities
got it austin with the last question
says when i look at bitcoin
i always go back to thinking that janet
yellen will be the last secretary of
treasury to fight bitcoin
do you think that the younger generation
takes higher government positions
regulation and therefore adoption will
become more bitcoin and crypto friendly
i'd have to think so i think
demographics matter
um and um you know the
certainly you know uh i feel like most
of the the crowd frankly
in bitcoin is younger than i am um and
you know what i don't see too many
people that are that much older
um it's certainly a smaller percentage
and so i think the law of numbers kind
of tells you
that we have certainly have a better
shot to be have bitcoin and crypto
friendly people
um you know holding high offices um as
can
the years go on michael i'm 33 which i
still say is my early 30s
and somehow i feel old when uh when i
talk to people so when i talk to
you know uh folks who have been in
traditional finance for 40 years
i'm like man if i feel they they're like
this is a whole new world
so i agree with you that the
demographics definitely matter
no i'm 44. and and the bulk of my team
at genesis is probably
mid to late 20s right and so
i find myself making seinfeld references
from time to time they're like what's
seinfeld
like they literally look at me as if
they have no idea what i'm talking about
then i immediately think about firing
them
so it's kind of where we are right um in
kind of how old we are kind of in the in
the space in which we work
that is amazing i'm sure that there's
great arguments over who has better
music
and the better tv shows and everything
else the challenge is i don't know most
of these artists that these kids listen
to nowadays and so it's less of a
conversation than them trying to teach
the old guy
just have to get you on tick tock and
then the world will be complete
it explodes where can we send people to
find you on the internet or
find out more about genesis and
especially if there's any cfos or
treasures that are
that are listening to this that uh are
interested in potentially learning more
about putting bitcoin in the balance
sheet
sure um so genesistrading.com is our
website
um we have a treasury landing page at
genesistrading.com
treasury um you can find me i'm on
linkedin i'm on twitter
um we feel free to reach out and let's
have a conversation
awesome well listen thank you so much
for taking the time to uh to do this i
think there's tons of people who learned
a lot
and that will definitely do it again in
the future palm thanks so much thanks
guys